someone wiped their whole Instagram
account and is teasing us now Frankie
Jonas it's so good to see last time I
saw you was at the opening of your
family's restaurant in Vegas so it's so
it's so cute I saw you two like in
passing at the Walk of Fame ceremony the
other day but uh always always a
pleasure anytime I'm around the Jonas
family y'all are truly the best but uh
Frankie Grammy's week is upon us how are
you celebrating uh the first time I've
ever celebrated by showing up to things
like this which is an entirely new
experience getting to be things like
this is crazy and an honor it's weird
it's gonna be this is I mean you're
gonna have a lot more events like this
to come because you have some new music
on the way quite possibly you might be
seeing me next Tuesday if you will okay
so literally Frankie wiped his Instagram
account he has one post up right now and
the caption is see you next Tuesday so
what what is in store what can we expect
it's a new single right it is yeah it is
um you know I've been working on project
for a really long time on my on my
lonesome and hiding it for obvious
reasons uh and you know I think I'm
ready to bring it out Bring It Forward
and see how the response is we are ready
for you to bring it forward now you say
that you've had it in hiding now I've
got to ask because you are a part of
such a musical family do your brothers
at least get to listen to it or are they
okay so that yes they do okay yeah no
they definitely do uh they've been a big
sounding board for me I mean obviously
they're pretty established musicians so
it's been amazing to have them in my
corner and as a some some advice givers
along the way now do you want to keep
this out like this music that you're
working on did I just manifest an album
Maybe
who knows who knows I got to be correct
with the verbiage here but do you want
to keep your music kind of separate from
your brothers of course they have their
own thing but do you is that important
to you to kind of
carve your own path yeah no I think it's
uh it lives on its own it really does I
think that there's not a lot of
crossover but there's a lot of influence
so I think that it'll be my thing and
they'll be doing theirs and we'll be
cheering each other on speaking of I
have to ask you because I I have watched
your brother's place since hotel
ballrooms like I used to see you as like
a little boy coming out of their their
tour buses I have to ask you the album
coming out May 5th what can you tease I
know you've heard it
it's uh I'll put it the way that they
put it uh in the title it is an album
it's an album
and that's all I'm gonna give her that
so yeah you are brother of the Year
keeping all those secrets
[Music]